Samuel Johnson in his, uh, in
the life of Milton and that,
that's the life of Milton
included in the packet. Um,
but I've also included
this on the handout.
A Dr. Johnson wrote that paradise lost
is one of those books which the reader
admirers and lays down and
forgets to take up again.
And we're, we're, we're used to
this, we've read enough Johnson to,
to recognize a
characteristic curmudgeonly,
curmudgeonly nest when it
comes to the subject of Milton.
But I think there's something to this
idea that we forget to take paradise lost
up again after we've laid it down.
Because to say that paradise lost is,
is not exactly a page Turner is simply
to say that we're already familiar with
the plot. We know of
course, how the story ends.
And there's nothing for
us in terms of the plot,
at least to anticipate with all that much
eagerness and our for knowledge of the
stories and works continually,
I think to reinforce our sense
of God's fore knowledge of,
of the end of the story. And of
course for knowledge of any kind, uh,
makes the end seem inevitable.
And,
and I think the inevitability of an
ending puts me Milton, uh, this idea,
it puts Milton and a terrible bind.
Any sense of the inevitability
of the fall really makes it,
it just makes hash,
it makes nonsense of the notion of any
strong sense of any strong feeling of
Adams and Eve's freewill.
And if,
and if we're disappointed with
the ending of paradise lost.
And I think it's safe to say that
Milton to is deeply troubled by the
implications of an end.
And so it's for,
it's for all of these reasons that we
can say that paradise lost is obsessed
with the problem of its own,
the problem of its own ending.
Now we remember that Milton had devoted
enormous sums of energy as a young man
and anticipating his,
his own,
and he was contingent continually looking
ahead to the, to the writing of a,
of a poem that after times
would not willingly let die.
You'll remember that, uh,
that sentence from the reason of
church government in the, in the 1640s,
he looked ahead to a con,
a political future in which the reformed
government would usher in the reign of
Christ at the end of time.
And his early poems are filled
with brief lyric narratives of,
of anticipation.
I'll,
I'll just enumerate a few of
those or will remind you of them.
The Ne they naitivity owed
had anticipated a few times.
The apocalypse comas had anticipated,
well had anticipated that
the apocalypse as well,
but it also anticipated the
eventual marriage of the lady, uh,
enlisted us anticipated among so many
other things. The undying fame of the,
of the poet and Adam too,
in and books 11 and 12,
Adam seems continually to be
anticipating an ending, like,
like the Speaker of the Nativity yoed
Adam's always looking ahead to the
Christian millennium or the,
or the apocalypse and he's
jumping ahead of himself.
And Michael has always chiding him for
this, for this enthusiasm. And Michael,
it's as if Michael's job is to put the
brakes on Adams anticipatory excitement.
Okay.
Given that role that Michael plays,
I think it's all the more
remarkable that it's Michael.
This is our kill joy
archangel who's just as bad,
who's often just as bad as Adam in his
own eagerness to jump ahead of himself as
he tells the story of Michael himself
is the angel of apocalypse from the book
of revelation, as we learned from, from
David's lecture on Friday. Um, that's the,
the book of revelation is the book from
which Milton has taken has lifted this
character Michael and perhaps
of his role in, in revelation,
the Michael of Paradise lost
seems incapable of keeping
himself from the onrush
of expectation as he narrates,
as he narrates and what I'm supposed
should be chronological order.
But isn't that the
story of future history?
So Michael will narrate the
story of the apocalypse.
Four, count them four times over
the course of the last books,
once in a once in [inaudible]
11 and three times in book 12.
And in all of this eagerness to, to, to
imagine the final fulfillment of, of,
of history,
Michael seems almost in some way to
be parodying Milton Zone tendency,
his specialty, his own youthful
tendency to offer those, uh,
prophetic narratives of anticipation.
Okay.
Now, Mike is, Michael's focused
in the last two books is on God's,
okay.
He's essentially on God's providential
control over the actions of the
descendants of Adam and eve.
And so it's not,
it's not too difficult to see why these,
why these books just structurally, um,
are, are, are, are so troubling. Uh,
Milton is in the incredibly awkward
position of trying to reconcile divine
providence with the,
with the notion of freewill.
This has been his challenge all along.
And this is also the subject of a lot
of Milton's musings in the theological
treatise that he wrote at the same
time that he wrote paradise lost the,
the Christian doctrine. And, uh,
so I'm going to have you
turn in your Hughes, uh,
to page nine 84 in the,
in the Christian doctrine.
Um,
Milton devotes an entire chapter to the,
to the problem of the
seeming incompatibilities of
divine providence and human
freewill.
And he finds himself continually knocking
up against the representation of the
providential God that he finds in the,
that he finds in the Bible.
So this is a Christian doctrine.
This is page nine 84 this is where
Milton tries to carve out a space for
freewill and the face of so much
contrary evidence in scripture.
This is on the,
the top of the right hand column,
I believe this is, yes,
this is also on the handout.
Okay. Milton speaking on a
speaking about divine providence,
which is obviously on some level,
it's a sensitive subject,
maybe a sore subject for such a
strong believer in human freewill.
And he's quoting here the scriptural
accounts of the voluntary,
what he calls the voluntary
actions of the deity.
Those moments in which God is acting
out of his own inscrutable will.
So here we have Melton.
I'm acting writing very
systematically voluntary actions.
Second chronicles 10 15,
this is an example.
So the king hearkened not unto the
people for the cause was of God.
And then again from proverbs,
a man's heart divides us this way,
but Jehovah Directeth,
his steps and man's goings are of Jehovah
and the King's heart is at the hand of
Jehovah as the river rivers of water.
He turneth it,
whither soever he will. And
this from Jeremiah, Oh Jehovah,
I know that the way of
man is not in himself.
Now why,
why would Milton do this?
Why would he cite these that
beside these scriptures for, from,
from Milton's point of view and actually
from the point of view of a lot of, uh,
a lot of 17th century Christians,
they would have,
these would have to be bone chilling
statements of the absolute divine control
over our lives.
The verses from scripture,
the millstones quoting here at seem
to admit of nothing like freewill.
And they conjure an image of God who
controls us as a puppeteer would control
his, his puppets. And this surely
this has to make Milton nervous.
And so after quoting instances of
divine action, that seemed clearly,
I think to counter the idea of
the power of human freewill.
Milton ads this, and it's
utterly sublime in this.
However, there is no infringement
on the liberty of the human will,
otherwise man would be deprived
of the power of free agency.
Otherwise, um, it's, uh,
it's, it's slightly, uh,
loose, uh, logic, but it's a,
it's extraordinarily heartfelt.
Milton is telling us once again that it
has to mean what I know it should mean.
It wouldn't make sense otherwise. Um, so,
so we face his head on
the most recalcitrant,
recalcitrant passages of the Bible and
he simply forces them to mean what he
needs them to mean.
And this is precisely the challenge that
Milton has confronted with in books 11
and 12.
The Bible had already written the story
of man after the fall and for most of 11
and 12, Milton has really forced
to amplify. He has, he's, he's,
he's pretty constrained here to amplify
and elaborate on the chapters in
genesis.
This is chapters four through 11 in
the book of Genesis that released speed
through generations of, in the,
in the course of a few pages.
Okay.
Now, the most important
biblical texts that, uh,
to my mind that Milton has to confront
is the genesis account of the expulsion.
This is the moment at which Adam and
Eve are actually forced to lose their
paradise. And this is of course,
the moment that's heralded the,
the loss that's heralded
in the poems title.
And so I think we have
to assume that this, uh,
this moment has a privileged
position in Milton's poem.
So this is the text as it appears in,
in Genesis.
And I've also included
this on the handout.
Okay?
This is all we learn about the expulsion
from genesis and the Lord. God said,
behold,
the man is become as one of
us to know good and evil,
and now lest he put forth his hand and
take also of the tree of life and eat and
live forever,
okay?
Therefore,
the Lord God sent him forth from the
garden of Eden to till the ground from
whence he was taken.
Okay?
So he drove out the man
by,
by any standard, I think that we could
comfortably identify as miltonic.
This text portrays a god. That's
the, that that's unjustifiable.
Okay.
We've seen this argument before
though. Um, you'll remember Satan,
Satan had accused God of jealousy,
uh, when, when Satan was tempting eve.
And if Satan was telling you,
God doesn't want you to eat the fruit
because he doesn't want you to become a
God like him, uh, uh, being
with the superior knowledge of,
of good and evil and [inaudible].
And we of course rallied
to dismiss Satan's claim as
yet another example of, of,
of his tendency to lie and to deceive.
But Satan is a,
I mean,
it seems that Milton Satan has
only gotten this idea from the,
from the words of God and
the book of Genesis itself.
What kind of God as genesis portray here,
if not that of a vulnerable and in some
way desperate deity who doesn't fact
punish man out of out of a degree of,
uh,
of jealousy and maybe
even maybe even vengeance.
God here has to force Adam and eve
out of the garden to keep them from
encroaching on any more of his honor,
any more of his privileges or of his
territory to keep them from achieving the
state of the mortality to the
only God himself. And joys.
Now, as you can imagine, um,
this biblical passage has been
troubling to generations of, uh,
of readers of the Bible and specially,
but bill biblical scholars and,
and the 16th century Theologian Calvin
was when confronted with his passage was
really forced to conclude that
God was speaking. Ironically,
here he doesn't actually mean
w w what are you saying? Oh,
you have to say something when you're,
uh,
when you're dealing with a
passage like this. Um, but,
but Milton's incredibly scrupulous here,
any fields he feels compelled
to reproduce this very dark,
very dark genesis text in his
own story of the expulsion. Uh,
look at book 11 of Paradise Lost
Line 93 in the Hughes edition.
It's page four 35,
and this is God speaking
less therefore his now boulder hand reach
also for the tree of life and to eat
and live forever dream
at least to live forever.
To remove him.
I decree and send him from the Gordon,
send him from the garden fourth to
till the ground whence he was taken.
And this has mean fitters,
soil.
And Milton depicts a god in this passage.
Who has all of those and
maybe even then some, oh,
those anthropomorphic qualities of the,
of the y'all way of so much of genesis
and God to hear is distinctly human in
personality. And, and he's,
he's able without hesitation to
intervene in the lives of, in,
in the affairs of man, in order to,
to effect his desire for punishment.
And,
and,
and I take this to be precisely that
type of God that Milton is trying to
counteract or to do a way with throughout
so much of the Christian doctrine of
God who is all encompassing.
We'll just steam rolls
right over the freewill,
the free agency of human individuals.
And,
but nonetheless, we have this
passage in the poem and you can, uh,
it's not hard to see that the
moment of expulsion is a crisis,
a crisis moment in paradise lost.
It's not only that point at
which paradise gets lost,
it's also that moment I think in
which Milton is most hard pressed to,
to depict who's a god, whose
actions are justifiable, whose,
whose behavior can be reconciled with
all of the claims of reason that Milton
wants to hold him too.
And,
and it's because of the moment of the
actual expulsion is such a crisis that
Milton provides us with an
alternative understanding of it.
Uh, and this, this,
I believe this is the conversation between
the father and the son at line 45 of
book 11 page four 34 of the Hughes.
The Sun is just pleaded with the father
to show some mercy on the repentant Adam
and eve and the father. It's,
it's, it's, it's wonderful.
The father argues that he would like,
he'd love to be merciful,
but there are some things that are
simply out of his control. Adam and eve,
we'll have to leave the garden.
And the,
and the justification that God gives
for their departure, I think is, is, is,
is truly extraordinary.
So this is line 48 of book 11 but
longer in that paradise to dwell.
The law I gave to nature him forbids
those pure immortal elements that no,
no gross, no unharmonious mixture, foul,
eject him tainted now and purge him
off as a distemper gross to as gross.
Okay.
And,
and,
and we suddenly have a rationale for
the explosion that's really completely
opposed to the account of
the explosion that had, that,
that begins at line 93 and completely
opposed of course to to it's original and
the book of Genesis,
where did Milton get this?
He's made this up and suddenly,
um,
Milton has a god behaving really
very differently. Uh, God is saying,
well, I'd love, I'd love for
them to stay in paradise,
but you see there's nothing I can do.
I establish this natural law in Eden
whereby the pure immortal elements of
paradise necessarily inexorably expel
and purge anything a that's foul or
tainted.
And because of course,
the fall bodies of Adam and eve are
actually Fallon tainted the atmospheric
mechanisms already in place in paradise
are in the process as we speak of
purging them from the garden. Uh, these,
uh, they'll, the lines
are, they're beautiful and
they're, and they're shocking.
Milton puts in God's mouth an
explanation for the exposure of an, uh,
of Adam and eve that really runs,
deliberately runs counter
to the explanation in the
book of Genesis and I think
completely contradicts the one that God
himself had given so publicly to the
assembly of angels about
50 or so lines later.
And it's an explanation that
that completely counters
the image of the jealous
and vengeful God that,
that Milton inherited from scripture.
Milton is really resting
this poem away, um, from,
from its source and skip scripture and
he's pushing it toward an entirely new
genre.
This is something much closer to what
we would think of as science fiction.
I think then,
then any kind of anthropomorphic
biblical narrative and,
and Milton is taking a tremendous,
uh,
taking a tremendous risk and to embark
on such a fanciful flight of mythmaking
at such an incredibly important moment,
um, has to be seen as consequential.
And,
and,
and I think that Milton is taking this
risk for the purposes of his theodicy.
His need to justify the ways of God to
men here at last is an image of the God
of God who expels Adam and eve from
the garden for an entirely justifiable,
a rational reason here at last is an
image of a god who's not at all the evil
puppeteer who deliberately forces the
movements of his, of his human creatures.
It's a,
it's an entirely benign,
it's almost an impersonal God who
willingly subject himself to the law,
to the law of nature,
to the natural moral processes of nature
that are inevitably at work in the
garden.
This of course isn't the first time
that we've encountered, uh, this, this,
the, the force of contradiction. I'm
in paradise lost throughout the poem.
Milton has been opposing a competing
notions of God opposing accounts of,
of crucial events. Um, you'll remember
a Rafi feels account of creation in,
in book seven in which Milton had
opposed the literal, the, the,
the anthropomorphic story of genesis
with his own really wildly original.
I'm incredibly beautiful. A story of
something like a natural self creation.
And, and, and,
and there are two accounts as I mentioned
in the last class to accounts of,
of Noah's flood, in, in Michael Zone,
in Michael Zone, a history lesson.
Events,
events are continually being related
twice and sometimes even three times in
paradise lost. And, and the purpose
of these narrative repetitions,
um, I think has nothing to do with
the Milton's desire to make this poem
impenetrable, are just confusing. Uh,
Milton is juxtaposing on
something like a systematic level,
I think juxtaposing the
poems, official, uh,
theological reading of
events with an alternative,
what we can think of as a naturalistic
or maybe a more rational reading of
events. And He's struggling
to represent a more palatable,
more rational alternative to the
arbitrary anthropomorphic deity who was so
capable of jealousy. And these
all too human motives, um,
that he finds in the book of Genesis.
So up to this point in Milton's poem,
we really haven't known what
to do with, uh, with all,
with a lot of these conflicts
and contradictions that
the poem was presenting us
with. Um, conflicting accounts of,
of key moments in Christian history
just seemed to be held and held in
suspension in the,
in the text.
And it's often difficult to
discern what we're supposed to,
how we're supposed to interpret
the relation between, um, uh,
opposing views or among opposing views.
And I think this is a problem that
we've been confronting all along is,
is one version,
right?
And the other version and wrong is one
version of satanic perspective on these
events and the other is a divine view.
What's the point of,
of all of these oppositions and conflicts?
Well,
if those are the questions that we're
asking and safe to say that Milton in his
magnificent genius has already
anticipated those, those questions.
And I think here in the
last books of the poem,
Milton is struggling and to some to some
effect to make some kind of sense of
this problem.
Michael presents a theory of reading that
on some level can account for some of
the confusions of, of
paradise lost. And it's the,
it's the theory of scriptural
interpretation known as topology.
Um, and, and,
and it had been around for centuries
and according to the type of logical
interpretation of Christian history,
characters and events in the Hebrew Bible,
which Christians called the Old Testament,
are seen as types of,
of characters and events
in the New Testament.
And this Mozart motive reading became a
way for Christian readers of the Bible
to reinterpret everything in the Hebrew
scriptures as to appropriate the Hebrew
scriptures, um, as an anticipation of the
Christian truth that would be revealed.
They believed, um,
later in the gospel. Um,
and this was a central way in which
Christians could assert some kind of
superiority over over Judaism in light
of the fact that Judaism had this awkward
but nonetheless, incredibly
significant temporal priority, um,
over Christian Christianity. Um,
so typology becomes a big deal.
And look at, uh, look at Milton's, uh,
dealing with the typological perspective
in Paradise Lost Book 12 Line three 10.
This is page four,
61 in the Hughes.
Milton looks at the Old Testament figure
of Joshua and he's not making this up.
This is, there's a long tradition of
thinking of Joshua as a type of Jesus.
And Joshua represents a in this reading
and the early version of the Jesus that,
that Christians come to call Christ.
And the full significance is of Joshua's
life can't have been revealed in his
own lifetime or actually during,
during, during anyone's lifetime.
In the Old Testament,
the full significance of the old testament
type isn't known until the emergence
of the New Testament anti type, uh, the,
the anti type being the Christian
fulfillment of the HEBRAIC type.
And in this case,
the anti type is the birth of Jesus and,
and Chris Christian exit gates.
We're constantly mapping out elaborate
systems of types and anti types as they,
as they read the Bible.
And there's a,
there's a very interesting book
on Milton's use of Topology, uh,
by William Madsen,
mad SCN called from
shadowy types to truth.
Look a look a little further
up on page four 61, uh,
this is Michael's actual
theory of typology,
a line 300 book 12.
So true meaning in the,
in the typological view of history,
true meaning emerges over time by
means of an historical process.
And this is how Michael articulates it.
So law appears in perfect man.
A bylaw.
Michael means a mosaic law.
The law dispensed on Mount
Sinai in the Old Testament.
So law appears imperfect and but given
with purpose to resign them in full time,
up to a better covenant,
disciplined from shadowy types to truth,
from flesh to spirit,
from imposition of strict laws to free
acceptance of large grace from survival,
fear to filial works of
law to works of faith.
Christian history obeys a process whereby
the shadowy types of the old testament
or eventually revealed and all of their
truth in the New Testament Old Testament
law gives way to new testament faith and
the laws of the laws of the flesh start
to yield to something like a
faith in the spirit. That's the,
that's the message here. And
Michael presents us, um, with the,
the official theological understanding
of the significance of Christian history
and this is really the official doctrine
of the revelation of all of the types
and anti types that Michael has given
us in this whirlwind history, um,
of life after the fall.
Michael is also doing
a lot more than that.
Michael's theory of Reading Biblical
history is also I think is also something
like a theory of reading this very poem.
He's giving us an interpretive key.
I submit to some of the most,
to some of the most difficult aspects
of paradise lost the history of
civilization that Michael offers
us is filled with moments of,
of, of seeming repetition. Joshua
appears in the Old Testament,
but he seems to point ahead to
the new Joshua Jesus. In the,
in the New Testament and these and these
type of logical repetitions are closely
related I think to the
narrative repetitions that we,
that we have in Milton's poem,
narrative repetitions like the competing
accounts of the creation or the
competing accounts of
the explosion. Um, the,
these are things that we've looked at
and the theory of the type of topology
works to make sense on some level of
some of the differences in some of the
conflicts among these repeated
narratives in Milton story.
Now we may have been confused,
we may have been confused about what to
do with the poems competing accounts,
um, uh, various moments
of, of Christian history.
And this is why this is where
the theory of typology comes in.
The old fashioned anthropomorphic
image of the, of the deity,
the images that Milton inherits
in large part from the,
from the text as genesis begin
to look like shadowy types,
the shadow, we types of the old
testament and the more modern,
what we could think of is something
like the quasi scientific rational
explanation in the poem of certain events
begins to emerge as something like a
type of, as a new kind of truth
that the shadow we types of,
of Milton scriptural literalism.
And there no question that that's an
important component of this poem. Um,
yield maybe they yield,
uh,
to the truths of the more scientific,
the more naturalistic side
of Milton's imagination.
It's not exactly the case that one
version is wrong and the other version is
right.
We could think of one version as being
an early literalist understanding of an
event and the other as a, as
a later, more, more rational,
more sophisticated
understanding of an event, uh,
an entirely natural as opposed to a
supernatural account of the forces at work
in the world.
And you can,
I think you can see Milton inviting just
this type of typological reading of his
own poem. Um, at the conclusion
of paradise lost. Look,
let's look at the poems final assembly
and just take a moment to be grateful
that Milton has decided to give us a
final simile after all of what we've,
what we've been through
with, with Michael. Okay.
This is a line six 25 of book 12,
page four 68 in the Hughes.
Now,
we've already had two anticipatory
narratives of the expulsion so far.
Uh, and I'll, I'll just remind you of
them. In the literalists narrative,
God explains that the,
the exposure will occur by
means of Michael's actually
shoving Adam and eve out
of the garden. But you'll remember
also that more naturalistic,
that clausy scientific version of this
story in which God explains that Adam and
Eve are going to be ejected,
ejected out of Adam by means of some
certain atmosphere, Eric pressures.
And here at the end of the poem,
we have what I take to be
the actual representation of,
of the, of the real event. This is taking
place on the literal level of the, um, uh,
at the present moment of the story.
And on the literal level of the
genesis account, a line six, 25
for now two,
nine,
the archangel stood and from the
other hill to their fixed station,
all in bright array,
the Cherubim descendant.
So you have these amp anthropomorphic
beings, the chair of him,
these angels,
these armed angels descend to Earth
to effect God's punishment of man.
And,
but no sooner has Milton given us this
literal genesis based description of the
expulsion.
Then he embarks
for a final time on,
on a simile that really throws everything
that he's just written into question.
The Cherubim have descended there
on the ground. Gliding materialists,
uh, materials is like a
meter there on the ground.
Gliding materials as evening mist risen
from a river or the marriage glides and
gathers ground fast at the laborers.
He'll homeward returning,
look, look, pay, pay attention
to what Milton is doing here.
He's juxtaposing the descent of
the angels with the ascent of,
of, of the rising miss. The angels
who are gliding materials, um,
is being likened to the,
the, the mist that's rising.
And that also glides. And, and, and
through this antithesis, he signals,
I think to the reader that there are
something like two competing perspectives
on this
horrible but sir consequential
event of the expulsion.
There's the literalists,
the anthropomorphic image
of the descending angels.
And you have something like
the naturalistic image of
the vapors and the myths
of Eden that will eject Adam and eve by
means of a kind of atmospheric reaction.
And it's as if God's expulsion
of Adam and eve from the garden.
We're such a terrible event and certainly
it is for us after our many weeks long
investment. Now in Milton's,
in Milton Story of Eden,
I'm so terrible that Milton has compelled
to suggest some explanation of it that
actually absorbs God, uh, of
any jealousy or any vengeance,
any of those things that
the genesis account, um,
invites us to attribute to God.
And you can see Milton struggling to
make this event more compatible with,
with his theodicy more compatible with
what we can think of as the naturalistic
side of his imagination.
So where has Milton taken us in this,
in this, in this beautiful. Similarly,
he's returned us here
at the end of book 12.
He's returned us to one of the most
beautiful similes of the entire poem.
And that was the similarly with which
he had ended book. One of paradise lost,
um,
book one that the end of paradise
lost also features a labor.
You'll remember the belated peasant who
sees or dreams he sees Ferrio elves at
twilight.
Okay?
Now Milton began paradise lost with
the claim that he would assert,
assert eternal providence and
justify the ways of God to men.
And it may very well have seen that the
beginning of the poem, that the idea of,
of God's Providence,
of God's fore knowledge for seeing what's
going to be completely at odds with
the idea of man's free will,
a god who knows what's going
to happen and advanced.
And I know I've made this argument a
number of times simply isn't justified on
some level.
This is certainly what a lot of Milton's
contemporaries thought and generations
of readers of the Bible before Milton
thought simply isn't justified.
And setting up a paradise that
he knows isn't going to last.
That will have to be lost.
But,
but if we were struck by the difficulty
of Milton's theodicy when we began the
poem,
that's because we had no idea then just
how far Milton was going to be able to
push our conception of God and our
notion essentially of divine providence.
Th Th th th the whole not the whole idea
of divine providence has undergone an
amazing transformation over the
course of, uh, of paradise lost. Um,
and it makes its final appearance
in the poems. Final lines.
Michael has just escorted Adam and eve
to the eastern gate of paradise and then
he's disappeared. Thank
God we, uh, we say,
and just before Adam and eve
leave Eden forever, they look back
some natural tears they dropped,
but wipe them soon.
The world was all before them,
where to choose their place of rest.
And Providence,
their guide,
they hand in hand with wandering steps
and slow through Eden took their solitary
way.
This,
this exquisitely beautiful and
quiet ending has always teased,
uh, the, the, the readers
of Milton's poem. And, and,
and our puzzlement I think derives from
the opposition here of ideas that really
seem entirely at odds with one another.
Adam has just been presented by Michael
with a powerful vision of the workings
PR precisely of the workings of
divine providence in the universe.
And we're not surprised to see Adam and
eve departing the garden with Providence,
their guide, given what we've
just learned from Michael.
But in the light of the presence of this
guide, the final two lines of the poem,
okay.
Always seems so difficult to understand.
They hand in hand with wandering steps
and slow through Eden took their solitary
way.
Okay.
The, the, the, the,
the 18th century a critic
and classical editor,
Dr. Richard Bentley was the,
was the first reader,
surely not the first reader
to be puzzled by these lines,
but he was the first Streeter to spell
out the difficulties of these last two
lines. Um, and, and, and, and look here
on your handout. I'm Dr. Bentley had,
had found the conclusion of the poem so
conflicted that he suggested that Milton
couldn't pee, couldn't possibly have
been responsible for them. These are,
once again,
the lines as a peer in our
texts are clearly the garbled
product of the confused
secretary, um, to whom
Milton was dictating.
So look at the handout.
This is near the bottom third of the text.
Bentley asks how the expression of
the last two lines can be justified.
I'm going to quote mentally here and
how can the expression be justified with
wandering steps and slow?
Why wandering
erratic steps very improper went in
the line before they were guided by
providence.
And it goes without saying,
the Bentley gets everything
almost consistently wrong
when he talks about Milton.
But you have to, you have to give him
this. He's an amazingly astute reader of,
of poetic tension and,
and poetic contradiction.
And it's an awfully good question.
How can it be that Adam and eve are
wandering at the same time that they're
granted by Providence?
Milton is able to pack into the
final lines of the paradise lost.
Really the central question
of the entire poem.
How can it be that human beings are free,
free to wander if there's a providential
force out there that seems to
determine, uh, their, their
movements. In other words,
how can God's fore knowledge B squared
or be reconciled with man's free will?
This is a problem that has been gathering
ground fast at our heels throughout
our reading of,
of,
of paradise lost and it's here at the
end that Milton makes a final attempt at
resolution,
a final attempt.
This is his last chance
at at reconciliation.
Milton tells us that the
world was all before them,
where to choose their place of rest.
And it seems on a first reading that the
guiding power of providence will assist
them in their choice of a place,
a place of rest. But, but it,
but of course it's more
complicated than that.
The word providence in this sentence
can I think also be the
object of the verb to choose.
Adam and Eve are not only choosing
a place out of their own freewill,
it's also possible that they're
also choosing providence.
And I think this possibility,
this,
this secondary syntactical
possibility is a,
is a really daring and radical remove on,
on Milton's part,
even the most absolute certainties
of divine for knowledge.
This enormous institution
of, of, of God's Providence,
even that can be subsumed within the
all encompassing power of the human
capacity to choose freely.
Adam and Eve not only have a
paradise within them, happier if our,
perhaps they also have a
providence within them.
And surely that is happier far as well.
You'll,
you'll notice on the bottom of the
handout that that Bentley proposed at the
last lines of paradise lost,
um,
be rewritten this. And so he
gives us what he is. So, um,
must've been what Milton actually
dictated but had gotten miss transcribed.
Um, and so, uh,
so Bentley wants to do away with all
of the ambiguity and he suggests these
lines as an alternative.
Then hand in hand with social steps
their way through Eden took with heavenly
comfort cheered.
Oh yeah, no, you have to
hand it to him. You, I mean,
of course it goes without saying that
he's a terrible, he's a terrible poet,
but you can see what he's trying to do.
He's trying to reconcile the entire
poem with a much more familiar, uh,
Sunday school image of,
of divine providence.
Bentley is just so much more
orthodox than our Milton.
And he wants to imagine a God who is
still capable of offering assistance and
constellation but also punishment for
from above a god who is still capable of
intervening in the realm of nature.
And Milton I think wants
very much to resist that.
And, and the world of paradise
lost by the end is, is,
is an almost entirely secular world.
The new world order that this great
religious poem has prepared us for is on
some level, the, the, the secular
world of, of modernity. Our world,
Adam and Eve are solitary here at the
end of the poem because there's no longer
a personal,
uh,
an anthropomorphic deity whose in
a position to intervene in, in,
in,
in their lives.
Now they may drop some tears
in in leaving paradise,
but they leave behind that shadowy type
of the personal arbitrary deity from the
book of Genesis.
They are free now as Milton is free to
choose providence by which I mean they
can choose an alternative
image of providential guidance,
an alternative understanding of that.
Now Dr. Bentley takes issue with also
an issue with the term wandering here
because he assumes that the word
wandering has to have its evil fallen
connotations that it did for Adam and
book 10 wandering steps for Dr. Bentley or
necessarily erratic steps since
after the fall. Of course,
the whole concept of wandering and all
the freedoms that wandering implied have
become suspect,
but now at the end of the poem,
Milton's attempting to reassert the
innocent meaning of the word wander.
All of the dock trinal structures of the
poem have been internalized by Adam and
eve.
By the end of the poem at some level,
this was the point of Michael's
history lesson. They, they,
it was his attempt to compel
their internalization of
provenance and wandering
can be seen as sanction now
and is innocent now because
wandering is predicated
on something like an internalized
providential guide and it's,
it's, and we knew this had to be
the case. Eve was right all along.
Wandering is in the end,
perfectly allowable in Milton's universe.
And we get to the end of this biblical
epic not with prophecy. Uh, but we're,
we,
we ended the poem in the mode
of romance wandering this,
this is an ending that's
not an ending at all.
But Milton successfully
resists the drive to closure.
Now we didn't know, of course,
when we started reading the poem,
just what Milton could have meant by his
desire to assert divine providence to
assert eternal providence.
And I may assert a turtle.
I may assert eternal providence
and justify the ways of God demand.
He told us in the first and vocation,
but the significance of this claim becomes
clearer by the time we get to the end
of the poem.
We move from a shadowy type of the
claimed closer to something much more like
it's the truth.
And there's a sense in which Milton's
claim to as cert eternal providence find
it may find its ultimate meaning.
This is,
this is one critical conjecture and
I'm quite taken with it may find its
ultimate meeting in the original there,
the root sense of the word as Cert,
the verb to assert, and you can see
this from the bottom of the handout,
comes from the Latin Verb Asur Ray rhe um,
to,
to remove from service to declare a
slave free and ultimate is declaring this
slave providence free.
And so I'll,
I'll conclude here with
a consideration of why,
what that alternative meaning of the
verb assert might actually portend there.
There's,
there's the obvious arrogance in this
assertion that that Milton might on some
level is assuming the
role of the slave master,
a slave owner placing providence
in the role of a slave. That's,
you know,
that's identifiably miltonic I guess.
But there's another sense in which
Milton can be seen as asserting divine
providence asserting eternal providence.
He's liberating a conception of providence
that has been enslaved and silenced
by Orthodox Christian theologians.
It's as if the notion of providence
had been enslaved by the literal minded
doctrinaire readers of genesis.
And Milton wants us to know that it is
our good fortune as readers of paradise
lost, that we have John
Milton, John Milton,
like some wandering knight in a chivalric
romance to come to come to the rescue.
You'll, you'll, you'll remember,
you'll remember the note on the verse
that Milton had depended to a later
printing of paradise lost explaining
why his poem didn't rhyme.
And Milton told us there that he was,
he was saving poetry from the troublesome
and modern bondage of rhyming.
Milton was liberating poetry
from a type of enslavement,
but Milton is trying to
save us as readers. Two,
I think just save us from our enslavement,
freeing us from the shackles of what
he takes to be, are the shackles of,
of religious orthodoxy from normative
social and poetic conventions to save us
from the shackles of the, of the
tyranny of literary tradition. Um,
he is attempted in
paradise lost to free us.
Finally from the troublesome and
modern bondage of literary reading.
Okay. I'm going to end the, the
lecture on Paradise lost there,
but I have a word to say about the
reading for after the Thanksgiving break.
Do give yourself some time with the first
two books of paradise lost. You might,
you won't, you won't be the
first to think if you think this,
that Milton is writing in shackles,
uh,
when he writes his sequel
to pet paradise lost.
But you have to give yourself a little
bit of time to appreciate the severity of
this poem.
It's uncompromising aesthetic discipline
because by d only by doing that will
you develop what I know will be your
ultimate affection for its mmm delicious
peculiarities. Okay. Have
a good, have a good break.